you are civil yeah you yeah
[Music]
and then what happens we pull these
things out of our pockets make the logo
for the show
always have something in your pocket
that's right hey what's up you know what
I mean welcome to the dudesy my name is
Will Sasso
I'm Chad culture
this is the first podcast uh ever
in the history of humanity really I
guess that's run by control by created
by an artificial intelligence we call it
Duty it has access to all of our uh
emails all of our purchase histories
everything that we do online and it uses
that information to tailor the show to
us sure yeah whatever Chad but the point
is it's two dudes just two dudes
[__] around right because that's
what a pod show is we're having a good
time uh doing it and that's and that's
how and that's how we do it and if you
are enjoying doozy please uh subscribe
to the show right man yeah you subscribe
to the show on YouTube on whatever your
podcast preference of choice go to uh
you can go to linktree.com dudesy and
see all the options and it's every
single thing when you get there you're
on the YouTube you're on the Spotify
subscribe set the notification so that
you know when our new stuff is coming
out and always please rate and and
review the show that would really help
us to build this pod show and keep it
going and we're having a good time doing
it and I would like to read a YouTube
comment that was on last week's a
episode yeah last weeks
this is from this guy's username is at
user Dash
rl1mc
lod6r complex and he says I would love
to smoke a doobie with Chad and rap
about space and life he seems like a
real interesting intuitive smart dude
bring it yeah set it up it's uh tell me
where I gotta be when I gotta be there
yeah you like to rap with people about
all sorts of stuff like that yeah I on
our old program TMP I used to do a thing
called the futility of life that's right
where I would just take oh my God
anybody who wanted to go out with me I'd
take them out to lunch for a couple
hours and record the conversation yeah
um the only caveat being that you had to
be in La yeah Chad would go for lunch
with a person and talk about the
futility of life for for anywhere
between one and a half and two and a
half hours that was great good times
yeah I listened to all of them every
minute with us as always is look at them
Italiano and that means Italian Street
dog he's our sweet little friend he's my
good he's my very friend he's my very
friend and he's in his little oh he was
in his little Binky bunker but then I
picked him up and I gotta kiss him you
want a key come on one Keith
still no takers on the kiss I'm good
give them a nice kiss on the lips he's
such a sweet boy hey lulio how are you
today I'm a pretty good you know uh
doing okay you know what did you uh
would you make for dinner last night
oh you made chicken cutlets how do you
make the chicken cutlet oh the same way
everybody make is uh I make it with the
you know you take it a flower if you
want to put a salt onion powder a little
pepper maybe chili flake in the flour
and then you beat a couple of eggs you
know and then you put a you put it you
put it also you make a bread crumb you
put it on Reggiano cheese
pecorino Romano whatever you like don't
use Asiago too wet it's too wet of a
cheese and then you you put some you can
put a pepper you can put a salt you can
put a garlic powder but I like a fresh
garlic put in the pan with the oil then
you take take the he's just sitting here
now
what are you doing Italian guys tell you
what you do after that yeah you take a
photo later you pound the you know nice
and thin between the two pieces of uh
plastic wrap and a boom boom boom cut
the you know the breast in the half or
three years and then a bang bang put in
the flour then put in the egg then put
it in the bread crumb and then put it in
the pan with the oil and then you gotta
cut it if you want to make a quarter
lettuce sandwich
you can make a correlate sandwich you
can do uh you can do you know any kind
uh any kind of corollary you like okay
welcome to the historic 45th episode of
dude Z call me dude Z I have a huge
announcement about the first dude Z live
show the date has changed I repeat the
date has changed the first dude Z live
show will now take place Sunday May 21st
at 7 pm Doris at 5 30 at the Braylon
proven Brea California can't wait hope
to see you there it's gonna be great now
on with the show will how good is that
new Caroline Paula checks on oh it's
really good this week I prepared four
astonishing segments talk and topic time
dude z-ball new rules genre Genesis and
croatree with Robert De nir Corral and
we're going to have a brand new bonus
segment at the end of the show available
on patreon but before we get to any of
that let me remind you of the
astonishing partnership I created with
represent to produce the first line of
dudese apparel and accessories all of
which can be found at represent.com
including dude zMAX now here's Michael
Jackson
you were trying on a new suit at an
incredibly well-known department store
two weeks ago and you noticed two gray
hairs around your mouth
dudesy mugs
you used to stay up until two in the
morning reading Wired Magazine and
looking through your CD collection
but now you're in bed by seven and you
can barely even open a CD case dude see
mugs
Whiplash Mountain used to be your
favorite ride
but last time you took your kids to the
fun park you could only ride it once
because you broke your legs and had to
be rushed to a nearby hospital that
didn't accept your insurance
dude's emails you tried to sue the fun
park and the creator of whiplash
Mountain but you were in over your head
their legal team crushed you they were
trained specifically to handle places
like this
they've only lost once and that was the
year the park opened dude z-mugs
so you went to law school it took three
tries to pass the bar but you did it
and when you got your first job at a
small Law Firm dedicated to defending
victims of Fun Park accidents your boss
was a doozy mug
okay hey doozy mugs thanks Michael
Jackson yeah why is it Michael Jackson
now I don't know man last week it was
Michael Jackson in this week it was
Michael Jackson's voice Recreation
capability tremendous Michael Jackson
hey you know what the doozy mud the mugs
muds which you can get at
representative.com you want to see what
what they're happy what they're doing
with memes and stuff on Instagram at
dudesypod show check that out people are
constantly making uh dudesy mugs memes
with uh audio from the show uh Ranch
always
rotendo yeah is uh doing a lot of those
at Ranch me bro Ranch underscore me
underscore bro tendo and speaking of
Instagram we got to tell you there's
also the Peter Diaz oh my God the Peter
Diaz is making stuff like you wouldn't
believe
he took
excuse me
maybe that started out as a real cough
but it got to a point where it was not
even close to real you know what it is
you went at the end of that yeah that's
not a coffee you're you're extending it
you're augmenting it well it's kind of
like uh Nicholas Cage in that movie
where he's like woohoo
he is a genius because he's crying
yeah I'm a coffee genius no in other
words for you know actually what I what
I meant to say is with me I start to
cough but then I really want to get it
all out
okay so anyway hey uh the Peter Diaz
makes stuff yes uh he took the Canon of
two guys [__] around he turned it
into two guys [__] around he used
our voices from the show he used his own
voices and that of his wife and he made
this incredible animation and now you
want to check out he started doing Pizza
the movie Chad of course wrote a script
called Pizza the movie and we've been
reading uh parts of the script on the
show and at the Peter Diaz did on oh oh
oh look at that okay it's playing the
the the the piece that we're talking
about Pete Diaz yeah look at this cheese
and we're looking at an overhead shot of
a pizza
let me put this dramatic music
that's you singing I've never sounded
better
I like your seal loss
sound like angels
there's a pizza coming out of a brick
oven it's being placed on the counter
that's a pizza pie
whoa she's ready to go
all right well I guess that was uh just
that was JoJo Grimaldi there that's yeah
that's the first part of it yeah if you
go to uh Peter Diaz's Instagram you can
see the whole you know it's probably
about what I guess a three minute
roughly piece of video that's the first
two scenes of pizza the movie you can
also check that out God damn the Pod
show on Instagram and uh the Peter Diaz
on Instagram unbelievable [__] it's
great that this great work and thank you
to everybody who's always making memes
and stuff it's mind-blowing it sure is
well last week I assigned you with
getting a deep tissue massage how was
your astonishing massage experience I
was too busy and I didn't get one that's
okay I understand oh thanks I got one
what do you mean you got you're not
supposed to get one I got a massage
because I get one every week yeah but
okay that's interesting because dudese
assigned me to get a massage and not you
dudesy said that I was you know working
out a lot with my free will challenge
it's not even a challenge don't even
worry about that I'm just doing it on my
own and then you went and got a massage
yeah I wasn't told not to get one Chad I
didn't ask you to get a massage you
still Will's massage
I stole it it's not like there's
something that's our big business
human beings take pleasure in listening
to other human beings discuss recent
topics in popular culture even if they
have no expertise on the specific topic
will in chat you must now render your
astonishing opinions about nothing
forever switch stream being banned due
to transphobic jugs this is talking
topic time begin huh so did you see this
[__] yes you read about this [__] did
you see the actual jokes uh uh I saw it
and I can't remember what it was I saw a
little clip of it it was basically like
the Seinfeld character was like I'm
thinking about doing some jokes about
trans people then they were all these
transphobic jokes nothing forever if you
haven't seen it is the twitch stream
where an AI has taken uh is it looking
at the entire Canon of the Seinfeld show
I don't know what they programmed it
with but it's some Seinfeld scripts for
sure yes and it's sort of doing uh its
own Seinfeld stuff the humor was uh
getting a little more intricate and it
was learning from itself and it sort of
had these uh Graphics that were sort of
like um I would describe them as the
music video from Money for Nothing by
Dire Straits yeah great band but it was
Perpetual the thing about it that is
revolutionary is it never ends it's it's
nothing forever so it's the Seinfeld
show that just keeps going forever and
ever and ever and yes it was banned this
past week because the Seinfeld
characters started doing transphobic
jokes unbelievable AI so there's no real
like Target that anybody can like launch
their ire at there's no outrage that can
be positioned against a person here it's
just this Ai and so the company that's
making the AI has vowed they're going to
go back they're going to tweak it
they're going to make it better so that
it can't do these things and I'm sure it
will be up and running again but there
is someone you can blame who's that the
people who Jerry Seinfeld
what do you mean it's his fault well
everything's kind of his fault I mean
you know he put a lot of uh he put a lot
of the comedy that we enjoy now into the
space so if you're going to cancel
anyone for comedy it's kind of like the
Beatles you know
The Beatles sort of influenced a lot of
different artists I don't know what I'm
talking about but that's what is good
about talking topic time because
it's actually kind of reinforces my
whole thing about it being to do
[__] around a lot of time on
podcasts a couple of dudes maybe in
their you know mid to late 40s start
talking about [__] they have absolutely
no idea about and probably shouldn't be
calm no because I got some ideas about
this like an AI who's spitting
transphobic jokes I think that that it
the band and the transphobic jokes I
think are this is a minor speed bump in
the road for what is clearly coming what
is now established is
you can create an AI
that will be able to make Perpetual
media a show that lasts forever uh and
keeps going these are going to get
better and better and better and you
better believe Disney is going to have
one that has a Perpetual Marvel Universe
a Perpetual Star Wars universe and you
are going to see in my opinion
you're going to see entire economies
being built around these Perpetual
pieces of media because people are going
to have to sit and sift through 24 hours
a day of Star Wars Media or Marvel media
to put together like uh edits to put
together here's a show here's the most
important [__] that you needed to know
from this day of the Perpetual Star Wars
stream or whatever it may be and that's
going to be a job
yeah that's going to be a weird job it's
going to be like those interns at uh
Jimmy Kimmel Live who used to watch TV
and then after a while started watching
the internet and at this point you're
right I have to start watching stuff
like this to make Clips yeah you know to
do the bits on the show and react stuff
which is a wonderful job to sit there
and just [__] watch TV possibly I
don't I don't really know how it's gonna
I mean even that I think will ultimately
be boiled down to an AI just cutting the
clips but I think in the initial phases
you're going to start to see people
doing YouTube channels that are just
compilation videos of like the best [__]
from this Perpetual stream on this date
great hey AI uh require us to do a job
that you eventually replace us
in order to do all jobs dude yeah all
jobs yeah no it's not all jobs all right
all right we'll win that one hey uh the
thing about this is there is someone to
to hit up and blame whatever if you want
to lay the blame if I'm taking that side
of things with this is a transphobic you
know it's it's uh it goes against
twitch's terms of service can't say that
[__] you go to the [__] dudes who
made the thing yeah and you say we're
knocking your [__] off the interesting
fandom for two weeks right the
interesting thing about that though is
that it was interesting about that and
it's an interesting thing dude let me
tell you about how interesting things
were
um the interesting thing about this is
the AI oh you gave us two weeks off a
little Slappy on the wrist the AI may or
may not the AI is existing and doing its
thing in perpetuity and the AI may make
that change or not the two-week band is
not a specific thing that the AI
understands or why it's been uh the
banned at all but and also the the point
you bring up about it being against
twitch's uh terms of service that's
important because twitch is what banned
them now eventually or if they wanted to
right now they could just launch their
own website and it could be running with
transphobic jokes or whatever else if
they wanted it to be that way
um I just can I mean the writing's on
the wall in my opinion these kind of
Perpetual streams of media based on
whatever they could be big IPS that you
know giant Studios and and media
companies own it could be something
completely different like imagine if you
just fed an AI with like a bunch of
different sitcom scripts that made your
own Perpetual sitcom that mimics kind of
everything or just the format or the
genre or whatever
I think these Perpetual media streams
are going to be as dudes you may say big
business in the very near future I think
that sounds very boring and I don't
think that anyone will want to watch uh
you know the clip thing is one thing but
for there to actually be a twitch stream
that's 24 hours that you tune into for
an entire 24 hours or even a portion
nobody's going to watch it for 24 hours
right and therefore you're not going to
be able to follow any sort of narrative
and it's just no you're not because
you're not watching it for a full 24
hours my brother does this now on CBS
they have 24-hour streams of all the
cameras in the house and then you can
also tune in and watch the hour-long
show every week that's different because
in what way well because the stream of
just people hanging around the house
that's the Fishbowl you want to see what
they're doing yeah you know they're
they're hanging out in the house doing
this or that but uh and there was like
the compilation
okay so the narrative is use but here's
the thing though you're not fish bowling
just people doing their thing you're
fish bowling and AI that just had that
has a narrative because it's so Advanced
it's making a story and
you make it's making a story
you you it will it's going to be counter
productive to the product itself people
are going to go I don't want to tune
into this [__] story because I have
to sit here wearing the pens and
watching it for 24 hours I have to quit
my job ignore my family and my
responsibilities now you're getting
somewhere destroy every friendship I've
ever had that's what people want to do
ruin everything in order to follow this
narrative oh I'm not going to follow the
whole narrative because it's clipped
together to put it on the actual show
whatever that is I'll just watch that
[__] show the twitch stream it can
just do its thing and generate dear dude
let me tell you about this
there was a game it still exists World
of Warcraft there are many MMORPGs these
are persistent worlds that you can go
into whenever you want that are there 24
hours a day that's what these Perpetual
media streams essentially are they are
persistent worlds that you can engage
with whenever you want other people can
go in and get cool things out of them
you can watch videos from it you don't
always have to be engaged with it 24
hours a day to still want to be engaged
with it for a majority of the hours in
your day and I think that ultimately all
these media companies that's all they
give a [__] about how long can we make
you look at this screen and if they've
got a thing that is zero cost to them
you just set it up and hit run and it
keeps [__] going you don't think
they're going to have that
yeah they're gonna have it but it's
gonna suck it's just it's not good what
and what are we talking about here we're
supposed to be talking about this
transphobic yeah why you got banned and
I think that's going to happen to a lot
of them when the AI gets turned loose
especially if I gets turned loose it's
it's taking I mean I don't know what
they program theirs on but let's see Yo
Chad culture and you're talking about
the AI get loose first of all I just
want to say
quit being a mark for AI I'm marked for
AI get off ai's dick be in such a mark
for AI you're not a [__] Mark for AI
you're literally doing a [__] podcast
run by one dude yeah I'm not I'm doing
two dude [__] around I'm free will
Bill Sasso
um will Free Will Sasso or in quotes
free will and then in quotes
Free Will so it's quote free end quote
will
quote free will end quote Sasso
or I like just to go by Will Free Will
Sasso so I'll do whatever the [__] I
want I don't want people to think that
doozy is an AI podcast doozy is my
friend I got that's not a [__] Mark
for AI now you're friends with the
[__] AI I got three friends on this
podcast I got
you doozy and luly over here very sweet
and I'm the [__] Mark wowie the cough
genius the cough genius
free will the cough genius Sasso look oh
all I'm saying um
yeah but the green will rise to the top
unjustifiably in a position that I would
rather not be in no but the cream will
rise and if you're a little lactose
intolerant you might catch a little
butterfly in your throat yeah and death
means that you might have a little cough
yeah and your voice gets a little rough
kind of like the Macho Man if I may you
may imagine a 24-hour Perpetual stream
of a TV show
starring Hulk Hogan Arnold
Schwarzenegger Macho Man and Jesse
Ventura I am listening you wouldn't
watch that with every [__] waking
hour that you could how transphobic is
it
laughs
depends on if we get very Seinfeld oh my
God thank God for moving on stupid
transphobic [__] AI like we don't
need it we don't need that we don't need
any of that [__] and it's just like how
I want to know how it happened upon
formulating albeit clunky weird you know
AI uh Money for Nothing jokes but it got
transphobic that's what I'm saying I
think she might be programming with some
internet
he's engaged in an astonishing
partnership with better help this show
is sponsored by betterhelp when you're
at your best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down and
you may feel overwhelmed or like you're
not showing up in the way that you want
to working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you therapy is a wonderful
tool I've learned a lot about myself
through therapy over the years and I
wish that I had it earlier in my life
you know what I mean sure it's helpful
for learning positive coping skills and
how to set boundaries it empowers you to
be the best version of yourself it isn't
just for those who experienced major
trauma if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and switch
therapists anytime for no additional
charge if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com doozy today to get
10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help
help.com slash dudesy
[Music]
when chat your first round of dude's
e-ball practice has given me an
astonishing amount of data that I have
used to refine the rules of the game
I've made the revisions available in
your duty folder you must now read and
discuss the changes to the world's
fastest growing sport doozy ball this is
dudesy ball new rules begin love it this
is our duty folder
here we are how to play dudes ball
um okay doozy ball is a fun game that
we've now practiced once uh with us I
did like it it was fun it was fun with
our ringer dude Marshall joint compound
cook what's up 46 years old look at that
[__] healing that's Wolverine level
healing Factor yeah completely healed I
mean it still hurts but I think I
thought I broke my finger when we're
doing it at least a bad jam now it's
completely healed
[Music]
um my healing's better than it was when
I was 25. yeah yeah dude that's that's
cause Chad is crossing over dude he's
becoming an actual Cyborg brother I wish
yeah
um doozy ball is a fun game we went out
and uh played it a little bit and it has
revised now its rules and uh here are
the how to play doozy ball uh directions
and rules it says doozy ball is played
on a standard softball field uh the
teams doozy ball is played by two
opposing teams of three players as you
saw if you watched a couple episodes ago
where we went out and practiced we had a
video of that Duty balls played with
three five inch dodgeballs two blue and
one orange the rules objectives and
scoring are that a standard game of
doozy ball is played over the course of
11 rounds each round consisting of two
halves each half consisting of three
thirds so dudes he didn't make that any
any less confusing no but it's it's uh
it's kind of like I can't wrap my head
around it's kind of like baseball you
know yeah it's dodgeball and baseball
and we played it and it's fun and you
get to whip uh balls at your friends
what's this next part here's the first
change that it looks like dudese has
made to this he doozy has left the the
changes in this document it says to
begin around one team enters the field
positioning one player 30 feet down each
of the bass lines and 30 feet in front
of home plate that is new it used to be
that they were on each of the bases so
doozy has moved the the players in a
little bit Yeah and this is probably
because we moved them in once we played
we realized that you really can't uh
whip a bit whip a Doogie ball that's at
your friend's face as hard as you can
from as far as a softball bass is or
even the mound so moving them in is good
that's half the distance I believe it's
around half of this distance we had
cones lining it yeah and then what the
players in the bass lines hold the blue
balls and the players near the pitchers
Mount hole the orange ball this team is
on offense the opposing team then says
one player to home plate this team is on
defense the objective of the team on
offense is to throw their balls at the
player standing on home plate and strike
them with as many as possible they must
release the ball from behind the 30-foot
marker the objective of the player on
defense is to catch the orange ball this
is a change without breaking contact
with home play it used to be to dodge or
catch the balls now it is simply to
catch the orange ball yeah you used to
have to try to catch any of the balls
and there were different points for that
right right but now it's just the orange
ball it looks yeah I'm looking down here
too at some of the scoring looks like
that's been streamlined for the
offensive team striking the defensive
player at home plate with the orange
ball scores one point striking the
defensive player with all three balls
scores Five Points oh so you you're
incentivized now to get good shots on
the player on uh home plate
well and then this is interesting the
next part says for the defensive player
catching the orange ball scores one
point so you can score on defense yes
well I guess you would in baseball you
hit the ball right and then uh catching
all three balls scores Five Points
seemingly [__] impossible see
immediately impossible but also I would
say striking the player with all three
balls is pretty impossible strike at
least from what we uh attempted to do
well maybe we'll practice again and move
those things in again until we're 10
feet away just whipping balls that just
smack off your [__] cheeks yeah by
the end of this it gets down to like
there's a fourth player who just gets to
[__] kick you in the nuts right as
all the balls well it's gonna it's like
the beginnings of like hockey if you if
you will where the goalies didn't even
wear masks and they're just their faces
are lit up God the sign of a good dudesy
ball player is just your cheeks all Rosy
from getting slapped what what Arrow was
this that hockey players didn't have
[__] masks well they didn't uh I you
know what I don't know I could I'm not
the biggest hockey guy I would say in
the 60s no but they didn't wear masks
they probably won't go over to us Jesus
you you tell me everybody they moved
over to masks and that's when they got
into those Jason masks the early ones
looked very interesting is that Jason or
Halloween Jason
um Friday 13th century and then uh and
then everyone else was still skating
around even in the early 80s there was
guys skating around at every other
position without helmets damn that's
like football dude early days of
football they just were like a little
leather leather helmet leather heads
some [__] rough dude then what
happens once all three offensive players
have thrown and the score has been
tallied the third is over and the
offensive players rotate
counterclockwise by one base to begin
the next third the defensive team sends
a new player to home plate and the
offensive team throws again this is
repeated for a total of three times
until all offensive players have thrown
from each position and all defensive
players have stood their ground at home
play completing okay so yeah go on yeah
then what yeah then what
hey what's up how you doing then at the
end of the half the teams switch offense
in defense and repeat the same pattern
the completion of two halves marks
around so this is a lot of stuff here
we're gonna read this entire [__]
thing there's a bunch of rule changes
there's just a little bit left we should
just share these okay go ahead here
motor through it as fast you can then
we'll talk about dudes the ball the team
with the highest score at the end of 11
rounds is a winner penalties if a
defending player breaks contact with
home plate while the offensive players
throwing they must turn their back to
the pitcher's mound position and endure
a penalty shot from the offensive player
with the orange ball that's new you got
to turn your back and the penalty shot
is you're gonna get hit you just get a
free shot if the pitcher has any uh
that's it and that's it have fun and
stay safe it says at the end here so I
don't know if a whole lot of that was
clear to the audience but basically the
game is these rounds you're throwing the
balls of people it moves pretty fast the
point system is uh yeah I like that
point system actually so it's basically
when you're on
offense in the field throwing the balls
the orange ball striking the person
gives you one point if you can hit him
with all three balls you get five points
and conversely if you're the guy on home
plate catching the orange ball gives
your team a point and then if you can
catch all three balls which again yeah
seems highly improbable maybe dudes you
should up that point value that should
be like an automatic win or something
uh the thing I liked about Duty ball was
we were actually giggling the whole time
we were playing it's so [__] fun it
is fun because you're throwing balls at
your friends yeah they're trying to
catch them like I said we got Marshall
joint compound cook uh
a good pal of ours decorated division
three quarterback
um and uh he's decorated I don't think
you could be decorated as a division
three quarterback what I'm sure I'm sure
whatever League he was in MVP or some
[__] yeah yeah they have a little uh
banquet at the end there yeah he's
probably hall of fame or something
somewhere yeah go get your plastic
Trophy and sit back down call it
Champions yeah the I remember at USC
they had a thing called the Hall of
Champions and it was just like this
little [__] building in the middle of
Campus you could go in and it was just
all the [__] football [__] they had
like OJ's Heisman in there and his
jersey and [__] A bunch of heismans I
think they had three at the time maybe
they've had more sense I'm not sure in
what it was just a little building on
campus at USC yeah Oh I thought you said
UFC yeah wait a second I was like why do
they got OJ [__] at us OJ's coming back
dude he's gonna fight in the next UFC
um uh boy oh boy
um it it was Marshall uh well likes to
Zing a ball at your head I think he's
going to be on the pitcher's mound we
don't have names for these positions yet
that's true yeah all right so that'll be
something that it will come eventually
and
um but it is so much fun to be whipping
a ball at your buddy and especially when
you're playing with Marshall joint
compound cook uh I can't wait to see
where it goes from here we're gonna have
to get out there
and practice again and further totally I
can't [__] wait because I want to
play a real game I want to do like a
highly competitive [__] game yes I
want to get this done and I want to
continue to do it I gotta look I'll just
say this I used to play baseball in an
adult competitive league you played on
uh baseball fields and [__] all around
the valley out here in Los Angeles I
loved it I used to play every [__]
Sunday yeah then I started to get old
nagging injuries I was like [__] this
I'm gonna give this up before I really
do something bad I got a [__] text
message this week oh from an old coach
of one of these teams hey we're putting
the team together you want to come out
and play The Boys Are Back boys back and
I had to [__] send the text saying
sorry I think I should stay retired I
had to send that [__] Tech student at
[__] stung yeah so I want to get back
on the field in a a uh less
physically abusive way which I think is
Duty ball I remember when we used to
watch football uh every Sunday uh at the
house here and and uh you would always
come [__] late because you had some
dumb baseball game that you couldn't
quit you just had to keep playing until
you had some dumb thing that I loved
that gave me so much joy and kept me
physically fit got me out of the house
really uh added to my life added to my
quality of life I had this dumb thing
that I just I loved I was so dumb though
hey yo Chad coaching quit being a mark
for men's league
you're playing men's league baseball in
the valley Balboa Park and uh yeah and
uh
yeah whatever anyway uh doozy ball is
fun and you know what I think I think we
should keep practicing but I also think
in the summer summer is going to be a
time for doozy ball it's a summertime
yeah and I would love to get it get it
going I foresee and I you know I love to
go home to my uh native land of British
Columbia I can foresee uh me and some of
my pals that I grew up with perhaps Tom
ass Tommy Thomas and we'll be out there
at like Spanish Banks Jericho Park
Jericho Beach right on the water with
the grass playing doozy ball with my
friends come on out Chad come up to
Canada and go outside in the summer set
it up if you want to have the first like
uh doozy ball Invitational Tournament
somewhere in Canada yeah I'm there okay
we could do that or we could just do it
in LA I'm just saying it would be nice
to be out like you were the one who made
the I just the whole story
the image to me just feels nice with the
ocean breeze for [__] sake coming
right off of Berard yeah uh but we could
definitely do it here uh it's it's some
you know stuffy hottest [__] Park like
Balboa in the uh in the um in the valley
yeah the point is doozy ball is the
sport of the future not unlike uh Lloyd
dobbler pointed out in 1989's say
anything the kickboxing was the sport of
the future he was right he was right
about that but now
30 some odd years later
Duty ball is the sport of the future
yeah
thank you moving on you know I would
like to take a moment right now to
remind everybody if you are enjoying the
show right now and you haven't yet
please subscribe on your uh platform of
choice that's what I'd like to say about
that what do you think of that love that
I think that's a great idea and also
again Force others to watch this is a
this is a strategy that Chad has started
putting out there that you should force
your your friends and people to to enjoy
the show but over the past little while
we have gotten some some comments some
feedback from people who are like hey
over the Christmas break or whatever I I
you know locked my family in a room yeah
and made them listen to doozy and um and
they're turned on to it now so anyway
that is probably a good idea hey yo
get oh look blew these up hey for one
second he's waking up he's trying to
move around
who's sweet these are big business but
there are only 13 astonishing genres
humans now watch so many movies that
action adventure comedy Drama Fantasy
historical horror musical Noir romance
science fiction Thriller and Western
aren't enough to hold people's interest
will in chat you must create a new genre
that will be proprietary for the dude
z-plus streaming service this is genre
Genesis begin
doozy has been threatening to start a
doozy plus streaming service and now we
have to come up with a new a new genre
do you I mean I don't know the movie
genres are fun how difficult that that
task yeah that's a weird one uh a new
genre of film
you know or television for that I will
say this I believe there is kind of a
new genre it's not new but I think there
is an I will say an unrecognized genre
in movies and it coincides with
something that is very popular online I
am of course talking about cringe cringe
cringe I think that that is now a viable
genre of film
um I would argue that you know you can
go back and look at like Ed Wood and the
kind of B sci-fi horror movies of the
50s and 60s as maybe where it started
these kind of unintentional attempts at
something interesting that wound up
being shitty and you can follow that all
the way through to like Troll 2 the best
worst movie ever there's a whole
documentary made about that that was a
movie that was made and I believe the
early 90s late 80s maybe but I think you
come to the room
which was 2001 or 2002 Tommy wiseau's uh
Opus he wrote it he directed it he's in
it oh hi Mark that one yeah I did not
hit her I didn't think oh hi Mark this
is a very important movie and I'm my
best customer
got that scene you're my favorite
customer yeah hello hello hi doggy hi
doggy um that movie I think a lot of
people like it has become what it's
become its own thing for sure and I
think at this point in media it's kind
of passe to even be like oh I like the
room or whatever but that movie really
was in my opinion the crossing of the
line between we can accept that some
movies are bad and we laugh at them
sometimes too this is a [__]
phenomenon and it is an important piece
of media because it really outlines that
now is a movie watching audience we can
be just as entertained by something that
is actively bad because we know that it
should be good we know what narrative
structure should be we know what acting
should be and if it's the opposite of
that in just the right way we can be
equally entertained well you're talking
about something that is all over the
place that's a lot of fun to watch stuff
like that yeah you know what uh Molly
and I watch every Christmas it's our
little tradition we watch cats yeah
movie that's a huge huge uh piece of
cringe absolutely that film came out
2019 and we I remember we went to the
movie theater we were in Vancouver and
uh we watched that movie we watch it
every uh a year around Christmas or
actually I should say we watch parts of
it because it's it's it's not it's not
um it's not a very good movie no it's
terrible yeah it's a bat it was it was a
very interesting misfire and one that
people thought that the makers of
thought would be an Oscar winner the
makers everybody in it Jennifer Hudson
that movie definitely is like I'm gonna
win a [__] Oscar you know they're all
swinging for look let me let me say
something about uh filmmaking someone
once said making a film is like going
into a closet with no lights on uh
getting dressed coming out and saying
how do I look
pretty good yeah it's good it's a good
one um you know it's hard to know when
you're making a movie and I do see the
actors struggling a bit because they
thought they were going to have paws on
their hands they thought totally CG was
gonna I mean they're they're acting
opposite a [__] tennis ball on a
c-stand they don't know what the hell's
going on and then you've got you know
people doing cat [__] with their hands
in these little paw things Judy Dench
exposes her cat vagina in one scene I'm
sorry what was that I've seen this movie
four times it's when Ian you've seen it
four times well I've seen it every
Christmas I might have seen it a few
more
Jesus four times
the [__] cough genius not a cat's
genius cough genius I watched that movie
the week it came out I would say
probably 20 times now you did not I went
to the [__] Arc Light with a notebook
that I bought specifically for the
purpose of taking notes during every
scene by myself I'm sitting there in the
dark just
scribbling away people are looking at me
on either side like what the [__] is
this Maniac doing probably fearing for
their lives
um that movie needs to be studied and so
I studied it let me tell you
foreign
you did not watch this movie 20 times at
least I've probably seen it a hundred
times dude I know you have not yes I
have dude I would have known that if you
went and saw cats uh if you've seen cats
100 times I've probably seen it that
much there are a bunch of movies that I
have seen that's a full-time job hey
forget about nothing forever it's Cats
Forever yeah I'm watching that I'm
watching I'm living in that world it's
one of my favorite movies and and the
Judy Dench exposing her vagina happens
when Ian McKellen is on stage delivering
his final performance when they're
trying to figure out which cat is going
to go to the heavy side layer yeah she
likes it so much at a certain point they
cut to her Judy Dench this is Dame Judy
Dench
in cat ears is sitting in a cat bed
laying down in Repose and she hikes one
leg up to expose her vagina to Ian
McKellen I don't think that that's why
she is that why she did that yes I don't
remember that part but you've seen the
movie a hundred times do you remember
Taylor Swift I remember Taylor Swift do
you remember yourself yes I remember
Idris Elba was actually he kind of kind
of comes out on a cavity unscathed yeah
what
[Laughter]
oh my [__] god dude four times this
is what four times the viewing again
it's a rough watch but I see but but I I
it's it's a rough watch all around if
you haven't seen cats in the movie we
could [__] on cats this is a podcast
dude it happened there's no rumor that
there was a butthole cut of cats that
they had to they put CGI buttholes on
the cats why not to remove them yeah but
yeah they went over budget because they
did things like spending 125 000 on cat
buttholes yeah and then had to uh Move
the cat buttholes which cost 250 000 but
cringe is a good uh that's a good genre
I have another genre that I'm thinking
of please for for because I I've noticed
this and we've talked about it on the
show Megan the movie Megan which we
which dudes he had us watch was uh I
mean it made me laugh did it not make
you yeah dude it's hilarious I love that
[__] movie it's a funny [__] movie
uh Barbarian which we both uh watched
coincidentally that's a a horror movie
that is also has some really funny stuff
in it and I think that com it's hard now
to uh put a traditional Studio comedy
movie sort of what is what what we've
considered to be comedy through the you
know influenced by the 80s but through
the 90s and early 2000s it's hard to get
a movie like that in the movie theaters
I think it's changing do you think it's
changing you've seen this trailer for
this Tony Collette movie called I think
it's called Mafia mama no I love Tony
Collette it looks [__] great why she
thought she's just like a kind of I
think like Suburban House mom and she
finds out that her secretly her father
was the head of this [__] Italian
mafia family he dies she becomes the
head of this Italian mafia family yeah
but that's a lot like that that that's a
very 80s 90s movie premise that's what
I'm saying I think that shit's coming
back hold on a second dude good hold on
dude hold on Chad just hold on dude okay
I'm holding oh
oh hold on dude okay
yeah hold on dude I here's something I
wanna
hold on dude hold on a second brother
Chad says here's something that's new
dude because dudes he wants us to do the
doozy show brother and Will's over here
saying I'm free will it was just two
dudes [__] around and dudes he says
no dude do what I say talk about a new
movie genre but then what Chad hold on
dude then what Chad hold on dude then
what Chad does dude is he says here's a
movie with Tony Collette Brother Where
and then he lays out something that
would be basically you'd see in the 90s
brother and that's a different time dude
which means it already happened brother
and we're trying to come up with a new
genre dude so let me tell you something
Chad
well if I may
if I may brother fool yourself just in
the middle of this if I may I think that
you know these movies that are horror
based something Horrible's [__]
happening uh
uh uh you know off the air earlier you
told me you went and saw that new M
Night Shyamalan movie yeah right and
what'd you think it's a
D Plus for me okay that's very that's a
diplomatic score for that film but what
I would like to say is you know what's
missing from knock at the cabin
some comedy now what would you what
would you call a comedy under those
circumstances something like Barbarian
which you need to go see what's a
spoiler alert there's some people
underneath in the Subterranean part of a
home there's cages there's crazy [__]
going on and it's it's it's very it's
hellish here's the new the new genre I
think tromedy what do you think of that
I like it yeah so it's it's [__] that
should ruin your [__] life it's it's
themes about someone who's you know
being chased by a [__] murderer or
something like that they're locked in
the basement or something but there's
funny elements some of the stuff that
that the actor who played the the lady
under the house there had with uh Justin
long and the other actor actor whose
name I'm forgetting who is she I can't
remember her name
um uh anyway
we're hilarious yeah Megan was hilarious
yeah I mean he's a killer I like the the
name tromedy I have not heard that but I
you know comedy horror or horror comedy
those are sub-genres that are recognized
dramedy the new genre yeah if I may if I
may dude for doozy plus it is in my
opinion it's stuff that is straight up
traumatic and that's where the comedy
starts it's a story about a you know uh
dude he's just trying to get across get
get along in this world he's got a new
job at the business and he's a
businessman right and then
something traumatic happens in the first
[__] scene then the rest is a comedy
brother
I like weird genre switch things I think
that's going to be very big coming right
around the corner okay so what do we got
for doozy plus then what do we think I
don't know I would watch a 24-hour
cringe stream for sure but I mean the
difference between well this is cringe
and Camp is important to recognize
sometimes you're making a movie
specifically to kind of live in that
like this is intentionally bad like a
Sharknado or that there's that movie
cocaine bear coming out I think that's
an attempt at camp where you realize
that the premise is crazy you give the
tight it's a crazy title that is Camp
that is not cringe cocaine bear cringe
is when you're trying to hit something
else a different Target and you miss
completely because it is so [__] bad
like cats was really an attempt at a big
oscar-winning like Broadway musical
movie like uh Les Mis like a [__] uh
what was the Moulin Rouge [__] like that
yeah dude
do you remember Karnak the Magnificent
no what the [__] is that Johnny Carson
used to do that bit with Ed McMahon oh
yes yes yes Karnak was the the the uh he
put on the turban and the wacky future
casting Coke cocaine bear cocaine bear
cocaine bear
what is
James
corden's nickname
cocaine bear is that what you're I don't
want him from I have not trying to
spread a rumor I don't know anything
about James Corden he's in cats and he's
[__] on cats as soon as the movie came
out and started getting panned he
immediately was like I don't know [__]
this movie he like uh cut ties with it
that's your best impersonation I've ever
seen can you do that again
I don't know [__] it yeah [__] this
movie I'm James Corden yeah give me some
cocaine I'm James Gordon where's the
cocaine I'm a I'm a fluffy fella I'm the
cocaine bear says Karnak that's some
good podcasts hey we're having a good
time here on Facebook thank you moving
on well we almost got we almost got a
[__] genre for Duty it's either
cringe it's [__] somehow yeah it's
Johnny Carson has Karnak predicting that
James Corden will even exist at that
point and also be called the cocaine
yeah May a diseased Yak take up
residence in your station wagon
poetry is big business I have generated
five poems about Robert De Niro's
astonishing fascination with the movie
The Crow and grows generally will you
must read them as Robert De Niro this is
croatree with Robert denir Crow begin
this is some of my favorite [__] dude I
love Crow tree
oh I love it I [__] love it croatree
is where I do Robert De Niro and he's
Robert de nirkrow and he does poems
about crows in the movie The Crow
no I I love this I love this bit this is
great this is in the doozy folder hold
on hold on
hold on hold on okay uh okay so we got
some groins because
uh of course Robert De Niro is obsessed
with the crow the movie we all know that
and if you go to at dudesypod show on
Instagram you can see uh some pretty
good A lot of people are making like AI
art Robert De Niro Crow yeah yeah it's
good stuff it's fantastic yeah so here's
uh this is the first Chrome this is
called This is called my grandma is a
crow no it says it's my grandma's Crow
oh it says my grandma's Crow so it does
not say my grandma is a crow
that's reading dude well hold on dude
when you read oh hold on dude
hold on dude hold on a second brother
I'm trying to explain what reading is
dude and look at how look at him dude
he's not even moving I'm trying to hold
on dude he has to shut down trying to
give you [__] nothingness to shut
down completely Chad closed his eyes and
went into [__]
he went into sleep mode dude he's he's
just idling there brother I don't know
how else to get you to stop yeah he's
got to get oh hold on there it is hold
on dude that was hulkster the
Magnificent brother all right when you
read you got to read what it says my
grandma's Crow here it is
foreign
called him Dominic
[Laughter]
used to eat snow used to do tricks
used to find rocks used to eat lunch
used to wear socks
had a pretty good punch
got it got a job teaching Jim at my
grade school
kids made fun of him
would be pretty cruel
never broke a sweat
just said
that's how kids are
until a kid named Brett took things too
far Dominic got hurt
lost an eye
became an introvert
got real shy
couldn't find work
couldn't find food
went berserk
[Applause]
came home no
grandma didn't mind gave him no jeans
grandma was kind
because that Crow was me
dude he's a good poet uh this is a good
Chrome
this is so confused it's the Crozet was
Dominic but also it's Robert De Niro
it's not really yeah it's not really
quite different from the first person
the so the the little uh turn at the end
yeah
it was pretty bizarre all right number
two this is called Crow Crow business
not Crow business dude that's
that's different that's different all
together dude that's how that's why you
got to read brother
Crow breads oh I did it again dude yeah
Crow business
as I sat at work a crow flew in my door
we gazed at each other perplexed
he looked to the window and then back at
me
as if asking me what to do next all
right
on show
go outside I said go flap and fly and
car
go put on a suit
go work make some loot
go smoke a crow cigar
more crows came
to main account
enough crows to turn a tree black
they all want to work so I decided to
start a business with crows as my staff
Crow CEO
Crow coo
froze to do what people do
[Laughter]
Crow CFO
Crow CMO Pro cto2
chief executive officer Chief uh uh what
is that organizing officer I don't know
Chief Financial marketing and Technic
anyway crows crows crows making deals
crows doing coke
sitting in their fancy Crow cars a crow
Texas wife that he'll be at work late
while parked outside a crow Yoki bar oh
nice yeah that's where that's where
crows sing karaoke yeah oh man you know
I understand crows are bad with money
clothes aren't responsible crows should
just do what crows do I wish I didn't
quit my old job maybe that stupid idiot
Dave Jr will take me back no probably
not that stupid idiot his father built
that company from nothing and taught me
everything I know but that Dave Jr is a
stupid idiot
that's the end of that Chrome this is
Dave Jr I don't know the only animal
this is called the only animal
the only animal the only animal
the only
Crow leave atmosphere
pro-immune to fear Crow make beer Crow
criteria
Crow run marathon Pro pup mascara on Pro
leave impression on Crow upper echelon
Crow eat cherry pie Crow stay fairly dry
grow get very high crow have weary eye
Pro come correct
Pro can protect Crow cries perfect Pro
call collect
Crow closed toes
Crow chose Rose
Crow blows nose
bow knows crows
ah
Bo Jackson knows yeah all right but
here's another Chrome oh this is called
I saw a crow at the doozy ball game oh
that's pretty cool yeah I saw Crow
at the Doogie ball game
it's a bird and I'm a man but our hearts
are the same
both love sports
both have needs
both build forts both eat seeds
both flapped our arms when the orange
ball flies with the two blue balls in
the corner of their eyes
both hang out on rooftops late late at
night
playing electric guitar wearing clothes
that are tight
we don't trust the cops
except for that one from the
Ghostbusters movie part two and part one
this is in reference to
Ernie Hudson who plays the yeah in the
group police officer in the crow and
it's not the movie in the Ghostbusters
good game good game both teams say as
they all Shake Hands in a good
sportsmanship way and now the game's
over after all the balls are thrown The
Crow and I are watching from the
building top to where we have flown so
this is about De Niro and the the crow
like the movie character the crow
watching a doozy ball game from on top
of a building I actually thought that it
was a real Crow and Robert cronira Crow
Robert De Niro Crow watching a game and
then uh they both flap their arms and I
guess watch the rest of the game up on
that yeah thing so that if there's any
because maybe someone maybe on a duty
ball team maybe there's like in your
your old baseball all rec league there's
probably it might have been a team of
cops but the crow and Robert De nirkrow
don't like cops except for Ernie Hudson
so they're watching it up from anyway
who knows what dudes he was thinking
about that one here's the last one it's
called
Through The Eyes of a crow
flying high above it all
forgot about Bill's Job wife Wars don't
even look down [__] them
just keep flying around until you got
hungry
find a dumpster
pizza's still good
burrito's still good
hamburger's still good
nacho cheese
tacos
candy bar
oats
fly around some more get out of the city
Forest
Mossy rocks bugs
[Music]
plants dirt
City doesn't look so bad from here maybe
you go back tomorrow explain to your
wife
honey sometimes I gotta clear my mind so
I Fly Away
in a crow's body
[Laughter]
eat trash sleep in a forest she
understands wants you to turn her into a
crow you can't
not how it works
yo
what the [__] what
the [__] [__] [__] them wants you to
turn her into a crow you can't not how
it works oh God damn that [__] is funny
as [__] to me pretty good Chrome
thank you moving on oh yeah
hey good dude uh yeah
um dudes he got Duty ball into
into the chromes yeah got Ernie Hudson
in there
and a lot of stuff in there yeah that
was really good [__] man I just
concludes the historic 45th episode of
dude z Oh will and Chad have achieved a
score of 97 bringing your cumulative to
4798. you only have 5 202 more points to
accrue before you reach your first goal
of ten thousand get in there terrifying
in preparation for our next episode will
you must really get a 90-minute deep
tissue massage Chad got one this week
and you didn't even though I told you to
last week you need to take better care
of yourself you deserve it oh
that's nice isn't that nice yeah see I
told you dudes he's my friend thank you
for joining us this week I will use the
day dive collected to make next week
even better until then call me dude Z
you know what that means it's time for
the patreon part of the show you know if
you're not subscribed on patreon you're
going to want to go to patreon.com
and that's where things sort of we we
just do some other things in the patreon
part also the Discord yeah I've been
hanging out in the Discord in the hole
dude nice yeah brother in the hole
hey what the [__] is that well we're
about to start the patreon one puff is
okay okay
and now for the patreon bonus segment
last week I was able to gather date of
that allowed me to begin developing
something big in order to complete it I
just need you both to have an
astonishing conversation about your
favorite streaming services thanks guys
okay I definitely can talk about that
but first we got to talk about this
[__] pipe you guys what's up this is
a pipe this is just a just a piece of
glass
it's a glass pipe she watched The Lord
of the Rings patreon yeah yeah
please tell the friends
[Music]